[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire les dirigeants de l'union
européenne se réuniront à bruxelles
demain et après demain pour aborder les
grands dossiers de la politique
européenne
or la hongrie et la pologne ont mis leur
veto au projet de budget 2010 21 2027 et
au plan de relance de 700 que 50
milliards de l'union européenne alors
qui prévoit de suspendre les fonds
européens aux pays violant l'état de
droit la hongrie et la pologne dénonce
un chantage et affirme par la défendre
l'esprit de l'europe centrale qu'aux
autres bruxelles
ce ne serait pas une question d'argent
ou de définition de ce qu'est l'état de
droit mais d'identité de souveraineté
nationale alors à qui incombe la
responsabilité d'un tel blocage dont
l'enjeu est considérable à bruxelles ou
à victor orban
et qu'est ce qui se joue là dedans pour
en débattre nous avons invité françois
xavier bel habit député européen c'est
vous qui avait conduit la liste les
républicains lors des dernières
élections européennes
vous siégez aujourd'hui avec le groupe
ppe parti populaire européen celui de la
droite dont fait partie le fit days le
parti de viktor orban qui a déjà été
suspendu en dise en 2019 qui pourrait
bien être exclue certains heureux député
du pp elle demande et qui pourrait tout
aussi bien partir ou créer un
sous-groupe l'intérieur du ppe
comme l'avaient fait les deux et
européens conservateurs britanniques
dans les années 90 alors pour vous
françois-xavier bel ami qu'est ce qu'il
se joue dans l'opposition entre viktor
orban et bruxelles aujourd'hui ce qui se
joue c'est un peu de tout ce que vous
avez évoquées en commençant c'est à dire
au fond c'est d'abord et je crois que
c'est fondamental une certaine idée de
l'europe de la place de l'union
européenne à l'égard des états membres
et de la souveraineté des états membres
je crois que c'est fondamental et qu'on
ne peut pas comprendre ce débat si on
passe à côté de cette question cruciale
de la subsidiarité c'est à dire de la
manière dont l'union européenne respecte
la souveraineté des états membres qui la
composent ce qui se joue c'est aussi
l'idée que nous nous faisons de l'union
européenne comme non pas seulement une
organisation internationale parmi
d'autres mais comme l'association deux
pays
son souverain mais qui sont aussi
démocratique et qui partagent des
principes communs
cc principe qu'il faut parvenir à
définir pour identifier ce que c'est
vraiment que l'état de droit est ce que
nous devons défendre ensemble
françoise grosses têtes vous conduisiez
la liste ump l'ancêtre des républicains
dans le sud est lors des élections
européennes de 2007 à 2009
à l'époque vous avez une ouais vous avez
été député européenne pendant quinze ans
de 1994 à 2009 vous siégez donc vous
siégiez à l'époque avec le groupe ppe
vous siégiez avec le groupe ppe et vous
aviez voté pour l'activation de
l'article 7 du traité de l'ue eux afin
de sanctionner la pologne en 2017 et la
hongrie en 2018 je crois et en 2019 vous
avez voté pour l'exclusion du fidèle de
parti de viktor orban du groupe ppe il
n'a finalement été que suspendu
alors pour vous qu'est ce qui se joue
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition entre
sorbonne et bruxelles bien tout
simplement c'est le positionnement de
politique intérieure
on se perçoit que l'union européenne une
fois de plus est prise en otage pour
régler des problèmes de politique
intérieure on l'a vu avec le royaume uni
on le voit de nouveau maintenant avec la
hongrie la pologne et finalement on
s'aperçoit que on ne respecte pas le
fait que lorsque l'on appartient à un
groupe
lorsque l'on rentre dans l'union
européenne on doit en accepter les
règles cela a été fait au moment de
l'adhésion de ces pays dans l'union
européenne en 2004
et malheureusement il n'ya pas respect
de ces règles alors je ne souhaite pas
qu'on doko systématiquement souvent
international souveraineté européenne je
pense que les deux sont tout à fait
compatibles et il ne peut pas y avoir
l'un sans l'autre effectivement mais on
doit respecter des règles communes
sinon l'union européenne ne peut pas
exister max thérouanne gastineau vous
êtes ancien rédacteur en chef des pages
politiques de la revue limite êtes
l'auteur du nouveau procès de
est qu'est paru aux éditions du surf
pour vous qu'est ce qui se joue là en ce
moment écoutez je crois que ce qui se
joue aujourd'hui autour de la question
de l'état de droit est tout simplement
du fait de savoir dans quelle europe
voulons nous vivre et non vivre dans une
europe au fonds de la coopération entre
des états qui ont en commun une histoire
des institutions et la démocratie ou une
europe qui cherche au fond à uniformiser
l'ensemble des états européens sous les
auspices de valeur certes fondamentale
mais qui aujourd'hui sont quelque peu
abstraite et qui mériterait en tout cas
je dirais une définition plus précise en
effet derrière la notion d'état de droit
nous mettons un ensemble de valeurs du
partage les européens
ceci dit entre l'est et l'ouest
il ya des différences d'interprétation
qui sont le produit de l'histoire qui
relève aussi de clivages philosophiques
avec notamment des majorité
conservatrice en europe centrale et je
pense que tant que nous ne tiendrons pas
compte de ces différences n'arriveront
pas à avancer sur une définition commune
de l'état de droit enfin david cayla
vous êtes économiste enseignant
chercheur à l'université d'angers vous
êtes l'auteur de populisme et
néolibéralisme
il est urgent de tout repenser qui vient
de paraître chez boeing supérieure pour
vous qu'est-ce qu'il se joue pas mais je
pense que on a là une opposition de
valeur je suis d'accord avec ce qui a
été dit de vision du monde qui sont pas
tout à fait les mêmes
mais qui sont qui sont relatifs de mon
point de vue à ce que un rapport au
libéralisme
concrètement on a une europe libérale et
même j'ai envie de dire aussi
néolibérale qui impose un certain modèle
de développement et on a des peuples qui
se crispe de différentes façons
d'ailleurs c'est pas pareil au sud à
l'est ou même en france
mais il se trouve que en europe de l'est
ça prend un aspect extrêmement
conservateur qui menace certains
principes libéraux et pas simplement due
aux libéraux c'est à dire des principes
de l'état de droit la dépense de la
justice toutes ces choses comme ça mais
il faut pas simplement voir ça comme un
problème de
l'intérieur de politique politicienne je
pense que il y a effectivement ici à une
forme de retour de l'histoire ou d'une
forme de refouler nationale qui est
aussi le produit de la d'une histoire
récente qui est la crise des migrants et
d'une histoire plus longue qui est aussi
les nationalismes d'europe centrale qui
sont qui sont tout à fait particulier
qu'on histoire un peu particulière qu'on
a parfois du mal à comprendre en europe
occidentale on va revenir dans le passé
parce que c'est à ce moment des ses
serres pour comprendre les oppositions
mais pour l'instant la sur le qui est à
l'origine du blocage
est-ce que c'est bruxelles est ce que
c'est la hongrie et la pologne
on a l'impression que chacun se renvoie
l'accusation de 2,2 chantage ce serait
l'autre qui ferait du chantage votre
avis françois-xavier bellamy clairement
aujourd'hui ce sont la hongrie et la
pologne qui ont opposé leur veto à
l'adoption du budget pluriannuel de
l'union européenne et du plan de relance
européens qui sont en discussion en ce
moment et ces deux pays l'ont fait mais
on ne peut pas leur reprocher de ne pas
avoir prévenu avant j'allais dire de
fait cette question de l'état de droit
elle cristallise des désaccords et
incompréhensions depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois plusieurs années même et
à travers notamment la procédure de
l'article 7 dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure et en voulant conditionner le
budget européen à l'état de droit avec
une acception finalement très politique
de cette question les les institutions
européennes au fond ont pris le risque
de voir cette crispation arriver
jusqu'aux veto aujourd'hui c'est pour
pouvoir faire valoir leur position que
la hongrie et la pologne ont opposé leur
veto sur le budget et maintenant
évidemment il ya un vieux de deux de
renvoi d'ascenseur chacun s'accuse
d'avoir provoqué le blocage actuel
ce que je crois c'est qu'il est
fondamental de sortir de cette situation
de blocage en veillant à essayer de
comprendre les pays qui ont posé ce veto
derrière la question de l'état de droit
il y a en réalité et moi je suis obligé
de le constater au parlement européen un
procès politique continuelle qui
instruit à sens unique contre eux ces
deux pays en
publiée et souvent d'ailleurs sur la
base d'informations qui sont absolument
fausses on a parlé là tout récemment
d'indépendance de la justice
on a entendu beaucoup de choses sur la
pologne la hongrie dont bien des
accusations se sont avérés être en
réalité complètement inexacte
pendant la crise du coronavirus par
exemple vous avez peut-être pu le lire y
compris dans des médias français on a
expliqué que viktor orban n'avais
quasiment aboli la démocratie en hongrie
et que par exemple il avait suspendu le
parlement hongrois
ça a été publiées dans des médias
français dans des titres de presse qui
ont pignon sur rue et c'était une
information qui était pourtant
totalement inexact le parlement hongrois
a siégé continuellement pendant la crise
du coronavirus et et le et le et la loi
d'état d'urgence qui avait été votée en
hongrie qui avait suscité tant de débats
étant d' alerte a été abrogée avant même
que l'état d'urgence sanitaire ne soit
abrogée en france donc il ya là
évidemment j'allais dire un procès qui
ne me paraît pas être de bonne foi qui
ne me paraît pas être équitable et qui
va toujours dans le même sens et je
m'étonne d'ailleurs qu'on ne parle
jamais quand on parle de l'état de droit
de la situation chez le gouvernement
socialiste maltais à malte une
journaliste a été assassiné pour avoir
mené une enquête sur des faits de
corruption impliquant le gouvernement
je m'étonne qu'on ne parle pas du
premier ministre tchèque monsieur
babiche qui a détourné 13 millions
d'euros de la politique agricole commune
pour une exploitation appartenant à sa
famille et qui a menacé de mort des
députés européens du ppe qui voulait
faire une enquête parlementaire sur ce
sujet là et là pour le coup pas
d'article 7 pas de discussion sur l'état
de droit
là pour le coup aucun sujet n'a paraît
en réalité d'où vient cette crispation
elle vient de la question migratoire de
la crise de 2015 avec le désaccord fort
qui a été exprimé par viktor orban sur
la politique migratoire à l'époque
emmenés par angela merkel avec une
fracture très forte hausse en europe et
aussi au sein il faut bien le
reconnaître de notre famille politique
et puis elle vient de la politique
sociale de ce conservatisme qu'on
reproche aujourd'hui à la pologne et à
la hongrie
on nous a conduits à voter tout
récemment encore au parlement européen
une résolution il ya quelques jours
seulement sur la politique familiale de
la pologne mais ça n'est pas rien une
question d'état de droit à la pologne
peut mener la politique familiale
qu'elle a démocratiquement
si des et il ya quelque chose de très
grave dans le fait que au nom de l'état
de droit on viole l'état de droit on
viole l'esprit et la lettre des traités
européens en prétendant imposé à des
états membres des politiques qu'ils
n'ont pas décidé et qu'ils ne veulent
pas et qu'ils ont parfaitement le droit
de ne pas choisir en vertu de leur
souveraineté
les traités exister définissent les
compétences qui sont celles les états
membres et on n'a pas le droit
évidemment de violer ces règles
fondatrice et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
derrière cette crispation sur l'état de
droit il y a bien sûr le veto qui est à
l'initiative de la pologne et de la
hongrie
mais il ya un très grand nombre
d'entorses graves à l'esprit et à la
lettre des textes européens eux mêmes
qui sont le fait malheureusement deux
familles politiques d'europe de l'ouest
en particulier qui ont choisi à travers
cette question de l'état de droit
d'instruire un procès politique ce qui
me paraît extrêmement grave et dangereux
préjudiciable pour l'avenir de l'europe
toute entière soit grosse tête
votre analyse est elle la même je
rappellerai deux choses d'abord cessé au
départ
le premier ministre néerlandais mark
rutte qui a été particulièrement
virulent pour défendre la position des
institutions européennes vis-à-vis de
ces gouvernements hongrois polonais
première chose c'est pas la france par
exemple n'a pas été tout à fait au
départ de cette démarche et là je
rappellerai aussi que pendant la
campagne électorale des dernières
élections européennes
cette l'importance de la règles de
conditionnalité pour l'octroi des
financements de l'union européenne était
vraiment un sujet majeur
donc c'est vrai que parlement européen
veut absolument que l'on tienne compte
de ces de cette question des règles de
conditionnalité
donc cela il faut pas l'oublier alors
ensuite que viktor orban se plaignent je
pense à juste titre que l'on ans paie
une véritable affaire politique
alors qu'il ne faut pas confondre bien
évidemment les questions purement morale
qui serait là l'interdiction de
l'avortement etc ou des questions très
familial avec ce qui concerne
véritablement l'état de droit c'est à
dire la liberté de la presse et
l'opinion d'opinion la liberté la
justice indépendante et c'est donc il ne
faut pas mélanger les choses et je
crains que malheureusement cela se fasse
y compris au sein du parlement européen
donc il faut quand même garder essayer
de garder un regard le plus le plus
équilibré possible ne pas incriminer
systématiquement le gouvernement de
viktor orban et le gouvernement polonais
mais néanmoins être ferme sur le fait
qu'il n'y a des règles qui doivent être
respectées
quand on adhère à l'union européenne et
que c'est vrai que là ont été acceptées
lors de l'adhésion de ces pays
donc l'état de droit doit être respecté
effectivement sawan gastineau qui
cherche qui alors il coûtait que je
crois que la responsabilité du blocage
actuel
un conte plutôt au parlement européen
vous aviez un accord entre les états au
mois de juillet cet accord a volé en
éclats puisque les parlementaires
européens ont tenu à ce que les valeurs
fondamentales de l'union européenne
conditionne le respect de l'état de
droit ces valeurs fondamentales elles
sont listées à l'article 2 du traité de
l'union européenne elle renvoie à des
900 comme la justice l'égalité et la
non-discrimination des principes encore
une fois fondamentaux mais qui peuvent
être médiatisé de différentes manières
en fonction des cultures nationales et
des traditions des mois juridique
ces différences sont fondamentales et
nous l'aimions puisque nous cherchons à
j'irai uniformiser l'ensemble des
valeurs européennes
il ya ensuite un passif entre le
parlement européen et viktor orban
je rappelle qu'en 2008 en septembre 2008
un rapport a été adopté le rapport en
sergent
donc une élue écologiste qui visait a
listé un certain nombre d'infractions à
l'état de droit constaté en dés quand
vous regardez dans le détail ce rapport
vous voyez un certain nombre
d'allégations en échec qui ont une base
juridique et qui mérite un vrai débat et
nous ton aussi qu'il existe un débat de
fer entre budapest et bruxelles
constamment mais que ce rapport comporte
également un certain nombre
d'allégations sans fondement juridique
et qui sont je dirais purement et
simplement des prises de position
idéologique on peut en listé un certain
nombre il est notamment reproché à la
démocratie libérale de viktor orban
d'avoir étendu la démocratie directe au
niveau national dont le le référendum si
je suis ce rapport irait à l'encontre de
l'état de droit il est reproché aussi
une certaine rhétorique hostile aux ong
un ensemble d'allégations qui était
vraie question politique mais qui ne
permettent pas de constater une
infraction à l'état de droit alors que
tant que si vous voulez les termes
format défini la confiance continuera
d'être consommée entre les hongrois et
les instances européennes et dont nous
nous retrouvons dans une situation de
blocage et nous aurons ensuite beau jeu
de dire les endroits refusé table droit
non ils veulent une définition précise
s'il vous lisez la lettre que gagnante
sa premier ministre slovène qui apporte
son soutien aux exécutifs polonais et
hongrois
si vous lisez cette lettre il dit bien
ce que nous voulons c'est une définition
claire de l'état de droit est une
instance à partial pour juger du respect
de l'état de droit
si demain c'est au parlement européen
nous constater si oui ou non des
infractions à l'état de droit
le parlement européen ne représente plus
les peuples européens est une forme de
tribunal des valeurs européennes et dans
ce cas là nous changeons d'europe il
faut le dire vite hélas se battre
habille également fait le c'est viktor
orban
les polonais qui sont injustement
traités non je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
soit si injustement traité il faut quand
même reconnaître qu'il ya des vrais
problèmes
d'état de droit justement et qui sont
pas juste des problèmes politiques les
réformes constitutionnelles de la
hongrie cesser la douce à parent
l'atteinte à la liberté de la presse
aussi en hongrie en pologne la réforme
de la justice qui en fait pose problème
sur l'indépendance de la justice
et là aussi c'est à la suite de cette
réforme de la justice qu'on a cru y ait
eu des tensions qui sont apparues entre
eux entre l'union européenne et la
pologne il faut bien comprendre pourquoi
l'union européenne c'est un système qui
fonde justement sur le droit le droit
européen et ce droit européen en fait il
ne s'applique par rapport aux cours de
justice nationale c'est à dire que vous
ne pouvez appliquer le droit européen
que si vous saisissez un tribunal de
votre propre pays et c'est ce tribunal
qui va ensuite tranché la question en
général auprès la cour de justice de
l'union européenne
si vous avez une dé justice qui n'est
pas indépendante
et bien vous pouvez vous passer du droit
européen et c'est le problème de
fondamental derrière ce problème justice
et aussi des problèmes économiques
et là j'ai envie de dire c'est pas la
faute aux uns ou aux autres c'est pour
moi la faute d'une architecture
européenne qui est profondément
dysfonctionnelle
c'est à dire qu'elle est fondée sur le
marché unique sur la concurrence de tous
contre tous la libre circulation du
capital du travail et ça eh bien ça pose
problème parce que les pays ne sont pas
égaux il ya des pays qui attire des
travailleurs de l'étranger il ya des
pays dans lesquels au contraire on a des
traces des travailleurs qui partent et
l'une des choses qu'on ne vous dit
jamais ici en france est globalement en
europe occidentale
c'est que ces pays de l'est et notamment
la hongrie la pologne mais encore plus
on va dire la bulgarie la roumanie
ce sont des pays d'émigration ce sont
des pays dans lesquels la jeunesse
éduquée a tendance à partir parce
qu'elle est bien mieux payés dans
d'autres pays européens en particulier
en allemagne
mais ailleurs aussi et ce sont des pays
qui se dépeuple et dont la jeunesse et
du pied ne fait plus d'enfants parce que
elle est parti ailleurs donc ils perdent
aussi en démocratie et ce sont des pays
qui ont l'impression de disparaître et
plutôt que de lancer des anathèmes sur
or ban méchant machin truc il faudrait
comprendre pourquoi il est l'élu
pourquoi il a été réélu pourquoi il
encore très populaire dans son pays même
chose pour la pologne et si on comprend
pas que en fait on a affaire à des pays
qui sont assez traumatisés par la
manière dont l'union européenne
fonctionne c'est comme dire exacerbation
de la concurrence c'est flux migratoires
extrêmement importants qui vont de l'est
vers l'ouest
le fait qu'on ait des salaires qui sont
quatre à cinq fois inférieurs en pologne
en allemagne alors que finalement ce
sont deux pays voisins
le fait que l'allemagne l'industrie
allemande en fait comment de l'industrie
l'industrie polonaise et d'industrie des
pays d'europe centrale et bien en fait
on a l'impression que ce sont des pays
qui vont des populations l'impression
d'être totalement relégué en fait d'être
des citoyens de deuxième zone
et je pense qu'on pas comprendre le
phénomène urban ou le pis en pologne ou
pas on peut pas comprendre ces
phénomènes
si on adopte juste une vision politique
d'affrontement entre entre des individus
et si on fait de ses dirigeants des
boucs émissaires ou d'épouvantail
s'ils sont là c'est bien parce que au
départ il ya des problèmes des problèmes
structurels dans ces pays qui à mon avis
sont sont le comédien son sens le
produit de ce dysfonctionnement européen
et mon sentiment c'est que l'europe
gagnerait beaucoup à comprendre ce qui
se passe
j'espère que là on est en train de 2,2
d'attaquer ces pays en leur disant ah
attendez vous à est exclue on va pas
vous donner de l'argent et on recherche
jamais à les comprendre et je pense que
cet effort de compréhension et l'analyse
de des dysfonctionnements européen et
doit être fait par les européens eux
mêmes
eh bien on va essayer de nous de les
comprendre
on a encore quelques minutes avant avant
la pause qu'est ce qui est est ce que
tout ça remonte
j'allais dire au rideau de fer c'est à
dire que l'europe de l'est et l'europe
de l'ouest ont re sont restés séparés
pendant près d'un demi siècle par le
rideau de fer
ça fait maintenant trente ans que que
ces deux europe sont réunis et or elle
semble condamnée à une espèce de deux
d'incompréhension mutuelle comment
comment l'analysez vous mccloud
gastineau je crois qu'en effet le
meilleur moyen d'éviter un faux procès
un mauvais procès et de comprendre les
antécédents de l'accusé au fond dans
l'europe centrale n'a pas tout à fait la
même histoire de celle que l'europe
occidentale
l'europe centrale et est composé de
petites nations qui ont longtemps vécu
sous le joug d'empyr et qui tiennent un
assez de liberté du mans conquise
qu'ils s'appellent en d'autres termes la
souveraineté et qui ont une conception
de la nation plus culturelle que jolie
dans les fait comprendre que c'est fait
contrairement à la nation française qui
a été construit de parole et a créé
existe à l'état où se sont même
construit contre l'état puisqu'elles ont
longtemps été dominée je les dis par des
empires jusqu'au siècle dernier et cette
définition culturel de la nation vous
l'a retrouvé dans la dissidence
antitotalitaire chez millan kundera
voulais retrouver durant
l'entre-deux-guerres
en tout un ensemble d'intellectuels et
vous la retrouvez aujourd'hui face à
l'union européenne que viktor orban
définit comme un ordre libéral un ordre
libellé et libérale qui ne considère que
les individus et non daily nation et qui
cherche à construire une forme de
supranationalisme sociétal qui mettrait
en cause l'héritage culturel issus
notamment de nos racines chrétiennes
racines chrétiennes qui sont rappelées
dans la constitution et donc au fond si
vous voulez moi j'aime bien rappeler
cette phrase de paul thibault qui
expliquent le populisme c'est un
conservatisme qui a perdu de sa
légitimité
je crois que à l'est
conservatisme n'a absolument pas perdu
de sa légitimité puisqu'il correspond à
une demande qui est le produit de
l'histoire et un sentiment que david
villa a justement rappelé la peur de
disparaître la peur de mourir
la sensation que ce qui est fondamental
est fragile et donc méritent d'être
défendus et donc aussi nous avons aussi
à travers la notion de droits
fondamentaux une vraie différence
nous avons une acception plus libérale
des droits fondamentaux à l'ouest nous
avons une acception une nationale plus
conservatrice de ce qui est fondamental
à l'est là aussi je crois qu'il faut
quand il faut en tenir compte pour
construire une europe qui va de paris à
dix on part se vit ou plutôt bucarest
pour reprendre
l'état le plus à l'aise on continue ce
débat juste après une pause
bah allons-y on l'a fait maintenant
[Musique]
après avoir affronté une première puis
une deuxième vague de kobe 19 le pays
va-t-il devoir faire face à une vague de
licenciements on a vraiment un problème
de chômage et qui va être explosif
n'en doutez pas un seul instant à cause
de ce capitalisme très financiarisé il
ya une précarité de l'emploi genoux
coudes et des plans sociaux étaient déjà
prévus depuis longtemps et le cog hill
ne sert juste que de prétexte
nous allons nous approcher cette année
saint d'autre de la barre fatidique des
10 millions de chômeurs ces destructions
de postes auraient peut-être pu être
évité par exemple s'ils ont lavé
conditionner les aides mises en place
par le gouvernement dans une crise il ya
toujours ceux qui trinquent et ceux qui
en profitent
là on voit bien que les actionnaires
sont totalement épargnée et tout ça est
géré je vous dis pas de la pire des
façons depuis des années ça n'est pas
venu simplement avec la crise tu peux
vivre
et
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres
et entre la liberté individuelle et la
liberté collective il faut choisir la la
la gouvernance est compliqué la pandémie
après les gilets jaunes le terrorisme
islamique ça fait quand même beaucoup
tout ça le fondement la politique c'est
la rumeur ont réagi à des rumeurs et
plus qu'à des réalités ça comme
conséquence que la politique est devenue
un métier du spectacle
la loi est un objet de communication
politique trop de lois tuent la loi et
les lois inutiles culé vol nwa
[Musique]
victor ban contre bruxelles on continue
notre débat avec françois xavier bellamy
françoise grosses têtes maxi one
gastineau et david cayla françoise
grossetête ils ont trouvé tous les trois
pas mal d'excusés à la hongrie vous avez
remarqué
ça paraît vous avez l'air d'être moi moi
pas du genre de vous peut-être peut-être
que sa perception que je donne je crois
qu'il faut quand même être extrêmement
vigilants sur ce que l'on veut faire de
l'union européenne cela a été dit
d'ailleurs au départ par l'inde et des
autres intervenants
quels sont les objectifs que l'on se
fixe pour l'union européenne moyens que
l'on donne à l'union européenne pour
remplir ses objectifs et il y a donc
comme cela a été dit aussi une
opposition de banner entre la cette
perception de ce que doit être l'union
européenne
et ceci me paraît quand même extrêmement
dangereux quand nous avons assisté en
2004 à l'adhésion de ses dignes de dix
nouveaux pays dans l'union européenne
à l'époque il un enthousiasme totale
aussi bien du côté de l'ouest du côté de
l'est
mais c'est vrai que cette c'est
élargissement qui a pu paraître pour
beaucoup à marche forcée concerne des
pays qui étaient pour la plupart d'entre
eux d'anciens pays communiste et cela il
faut pas l'oublier effectivement il ya
certainement pas la même perception de
ce que doit être l'union européenne
maintenant je suis une européenne
convaincue depuis longtemps et je me dis
que tout ce qui peut porter atteinte à
ce que nous voulons faire de l'union
européenne
cette union de solidarité union de
valeurs on ne doit pas l'oublier
l'union européenne ce n'est pas que la
possibilité de passer à un tiroir caisse
et et d'obtenir des financements les
contreparties sont quand même nécessaire
alors tout doit se faire je les dis dans
l' équilibre entre le respect doté de ce
que représente l'union européenne et ses
valeurs et puis bien évidemment
rencontre l'histoire c'est vrai que
l'histoire n'a pas été la même
sur ce continent européen on doit en
tenir compte mais il ya un effort à
faire de chaque côté alors le parlement
je suis d'accord le parlement européen
parfois houssin peu les choses trop loin
et dans dans sa majorité il ya il ya des
groupes mythiques qui sentait
extrêmement virulent contre les la
pologne la hongrie
cela ne facilite pas les choses dont il
faut effectivement que l'on sorte de
cette impasse il faudra bien en sortir
françois xavier bellamy il me semble que
j'ai le chez le grand honneur de
succéder à françoise grossetête au
parlement européen avec avec un an de
recul sur le sur le mandat effectivement
je crois qu'au fond comme le disait max
thérouanne gastineau tout à l'heure le
vrai problème c'est le problème de la
définition de ce qu'on appelle l'état de
droit je crois pas qu'ils aient de
compromis à faire sur le sujet de l'état
de droit c'est un sujet crucial
la question est très simple est ce que
les citoyens en droit à un vrai
pluralisme politique est-ce qu'il ya
plusieurs parties dans un pays
est-ce qu'ils sont vrais un vrai
pluralisme médiatique qui leur permet de
s'informer
est ce que les élections sont libres et
les processus transparent est ce que
l'enseignement par exemple est
l'occasion d'une vraie liberté d'une
vraie diversité
si ces principes là sont respectés alors
il a pas il importe aussi il importe que
les citoyens eux mêmes puissent décider
de l'avenir de leur démocratie
je prends le cas de la hongrie par
exemple viktor orban n'a manifestement
pas à supprimer la démocratie ont enlevé
puisque il y à des élections que
certaines d'entre elles sont perdues par
sa famille politique par exemple à la
mairie de budapest
beaucoup de parties se sont réjouies que
viktor orban ait perdu la mairie de
budapest mais c'est bien le signe que la
démocratie en droit fonctionne telle
qu'elle est vivante
de la même manière il ya eu des
élections polonaises qui ont été très
disputés récemment entre la majorité
actuelle et son opposition et le score
était extrêmement serré il n'y a pas eu
de contestations sur la manière dans
cette élection
c'était finalement déroulé après des
inquiétudes initiales donc s'ils
voulaient à partir de ce moment là je
suis très très sceptique sur le lexique
des valeurs de l'union européenne ce que
les valeurs si vous voulez
ainsi que des valeurs c'est que c'est
très relatif les valeurs dépendantes
d'une évaluation et il ya des choses qui
ont beaucoup de valeur pour moi qui n'en
ont pas pour vous et c'est tout à fait
normal et c'est parfaitement logique
en revanche je crois qu'il faut définir
les principes qui doivent nous être
commun et ces principes là pour le coup
ils ne peuvent pas être négociable
il n'est pas question que demain est lié
dans l'union européenne un dictateur qui
est supprimée la démocratie et qui soit
pourtant toujours membre de l'union est
financé par par exemple des fonds
européens
en revanche une fois que la démocratie
fonctionne dans un pays je ne vois
aucune raison de remettre en cause
l'expression légitime des démocraties
nationales et je pense que c'est
exactement cela qui nourrira
l'euroscepticisme dont on se plaindra
demain si l'europe qui se construit
c'est celle qui dit aux citoyens
vous n'avez pas le droit de choisir
telle politique migratoire ou telle
politique familiale ou telle politique
sociale parce que sinon on viendra
expliquer à vos dirigeants qu'ils sont
les dictateurs en puissance cette europe
là je n'y crois pas elle est vouée à
l'échec
notamment face évidemment aux grandes
puissances que nous avons en face de
nous la chine les etats unis doivent
sourire en regardant le caractère puéril
de nos débats lorsque nous écrivons des
résolutions qui parle de la politique de
la pologne par exemple sur la
structuration familiale ou là ou là où
la santé ça n'a aucun sens que nous
dispersion notre énergie dans des débats
de cette nature il y à des gouvernements
européens que je n'approuve pas il ya en
espagne un gouvernement socialiste qui
intègre des communistes ça n'est pas ma
famille politique
ils ne font pas des ne prennent pas des
décisions que je crois être juste pour
leur propre pays
enfin ils ont été démocratiquement élu
et je ne remets pas en cause cette cette
forme là l'europe à laquelle je crois et
c'est vraiment fondamental c'est une
europe qui est celle justement de la
coopération entre des états membres
démocratique des démocraties qui se
rejoignent pour peser ensemble dans la
mondialisation pour faire peser les
principes qu'ils ont en commun et ça
pour le coup effectivement cela doit
être non négociable mais il me semble
que ces principes sont directement
violée
lorsque nous contournons la démocratie
par des procédures parlementaires ou
judiciaire qui aurait pour but
d'empêcher les citoyens de ces pays de
s'exprimer librement
et ça ça me paraît être effectivement un
enjeu fondamental
il ya bien sûr des problèmes économiques
il ya des problèmes
qui explique les tensions d'aujourd'hui
et monsieur qu'elle avait tout à fait
raison de le pointer du doigt
enfin aujourd'hui il est très clair que
les polonais les hongrois seront les
premiers à reconnaître j'ai été en
hongrie j'ai échangé longuement avec
viktor orban
il n'est pas du tout anti européen il ne
veut pas sortir de l'union européenne et
il ne considère pas que la hongrie est
perdu dans son adhésion à l'union
européenne au contraire ils considèrent
tous les bienfaits que son pays tire de
cette participation à l'union et
notamment dans le nord dans le cadre de
ce grand mouvement qui était évoqué tout
à l'heure par un max et roanne casino
qui a suivi la chute du mur de berlin il
ya évidemment une aspiration à la
liberté et l'aspiration à la prospérité
chez ces pays qui sortent du joug
soviétique et qui l'ont connu
directement mais en revanche il
considère qu'il est très dangereux que
l'union européenne prétendre dicter à
son gouvernement et par là même à son
peuple une politique qui ne relèvent pas
des compétences de l'union européenne et
c'est là que me paraît être la véritable
entorse à l'état de droit
je termine simplement en disant que dans
notre groupe parlementaire que françoise
grossetête connais bien les les députés
hongrois du fidèle ge sont pour certains
d'entre eux pour les plus anciens des
des activistes politiques qui ont
commencé leurs engagements en étant
dissident face à l'union soviétique
ils ont risqué leur vie parfois ils ont
connu la prison pour avoir justement
lutter contre le totalitarisme
soviétique et aujourd'hui on vient leur
expliquer nous occidentaux que parce
qu'ils sont en désaccord avec nous sur
les questions par exemple de politique
migratoire je rappelle que c'était ça la
première question c'était ça le sujet
initial de la crispation entre l'est et
l'ouest
nous venons leur expliquer que parce qu
ils sont d accord avec nous sur la
politique migratoire
en réalité ils ne sont pas fidèles à la
démocratie et aux valeurs de la
démocratie et je crois qu'il ya là une
forme d' insulte n'ayons pas peur des
mots quelque chose dans tous les cas qui
est absolument inaudible en particulier
lorsque sur ce sujet migratoires nous
finissons par nous rallier à leur
position tout en maintenant le procès
permanent instruit à leur encontre
là je crois qu'il ya une véritable
injustice qui atteint en réalité toute
l'europe
david qu'elle a aucun raison un régime
libéral comme celui de 2
viktor orban est considérée chez nous
comme attentatoire à la liberté et ou en
tout cas la démocratie et là bas en
hongrie comme une garantie justement de
la démocratie c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas
la même définition de la démocratie
moi je suis un peu étonné de la
définition de monsieur bellamy qui dit
bon quand on a des élections libres on
est en démocratie mais moi je n'ai pas
cette vision d'un la démocratie la
plupart des politistes n'ont pas cette
vision la démocratie la démocratie c'est
tout un ensemble de règles dans lesquels
on respecte les individus mais on
respecte aussi ce nombre d'institutions
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure de la justice
on peut parler de la presse si vous
aussi si vous permettez aux gens de
voter librement mais que derrière il ya
pas de presse eux il ya une presse
totalement homogène qui dans lesquelles
il ya pas de la gare et ça ça pose là ça
pose problème
oui mais vous n'avez pas dit que le vrai
problème pour l'europe c'est pas juste
des valeurs comme ça comment dire eux
abstraite
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que
lorsqu'on applique des règles
européennes en matière de l'économique
par exemple et que ces règles nécessite
pour être appliquées l'intervention de
la justice nationale
si vous n'avez pas des juges
indépendants vous ne pouvez pas faire
appliquer les règles aux européennes et
c'est bien le problème alors je dis pas
que je pense que ces règles européennes
sont par ailleurs absurde mais il s'est
séparé juste un problème de chacun fait
ce qu'il veut comme il veut
chez lui parce que concrètement derrière
il ya des conséquences qui en tout cas
qui peuvent est tout à fait importante
sur la manière dont par exemple on
organise la concurrence dans la culture
pour prendre un exemple que je connais
bien
si les règles les normes de dire
écologiques sont pas les mêmes d'un pays
à l'autre et bien sûr d'avoir une
concurrence déloyale et si quelqu'un
atteint qu une entreprise hongroise aux
polonaises parce qu'elles respectent pas
les normes et que la justice hongroise
et polonaise qui n'est pas indépendante
n'accepte pas cela on rejette celle ce
pourvoi eh bien ça ça pose un vrai
problème c'est pas c'est pas juste le
migrant le problème dont on parle c'est
est ce que la justice à faire me
permettre de faire appliquer le droit
européen les règles communes dans le
pays encore en conséquence
l'autre souci c'est effectivement viktor
orban
il a cette idée
et de démocratie libérale je pense que
le mot du libéral n'est pas pris au
hasard
il s'agit d'un rejet d'une certaine
forme d'organisation de l'état dans
lesquelles les pouvoirs sont sentis
visés
c'est à dire que il ya le pouvoir
judiciaire parlementaire présidentiel
c'est le coeur de nos démocraties
actuelles avec une constitution qui
organise la répartition des pouvoirs
est ce là le problème le problème c'est
que pour certains dirigeants cela
empêche l'action de l'état l'action
politique et donc pour certains
considèrent que c'est antinomique avec
le principe démocratique
et s'il parle de démocratie libérale
c'est qu'en fait ils veulent une
démocratie qui qui envers qui
n'acceptent pas véritablement
complètement la répartition des pouvoirs
et ça pour moi c'est un danger alors
c'est un objet d'abord pour les
angoisses des polonais parce que on voit
d'ailleurs parfois les certains droits
individuels des minorités qui peuvent
être qu'on va dire que ce qui s'est
passé par un frisbee grattoir c'est
qu'on a aimé les ris est une pointure
entre des pays européens aient compris
avec la croatie fait partie de l'union
européenne avec la serbie qui n'en fait
pas partie et tout cela pour éviter que
l'arrivée de migrants qui étaient en
fait des réfugiés et vous savez que les
conventions de genève implique qu'il
faut porter assistance aux réfugiés qui
fuient leur pays et là en l'occurrence
se saisit d'un pays en guerre c'est pas
vrai que les hongrois était menacée par
une invasion de migrants non c'est faux
il émigre à la limite il passait par là
en vie mais il n'allait pas y rester
le problème c'est que on a un fantasme
tout à l'heure monsieur gastineau parler
de cet ordre libéral que vito en bane
voulait contre lequel le but en bambou
et lutter comme s'il y avait une espèce
de de marcia mondial qui allait imposer
l'arasement culturelles de toutes les
sociétés ou classique en europe vous
voulez supprimer toutes les identités
culturelles
ce n'est heureusement pas le cas et
d'ailleurs même sur l'union européenne
voulait le faire elle ne pourrait pas le
faire parce que tout simplement les
identités culturelles sont elles sont
vivantes en réalité et c'est ça qui
m'intéresse moi c'est que ce fantasme là
il n'est pas né de nulle part il
n'arrive pas de rien il arrive pas ce
que on a créé une europe uniquement sur
la question économique uniquement sur
finalement une organisation
concurrentiel
et à ces états là sont des anatidés et à
quillan se sont partiellement perdants
parce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
leur jeunesse éduquée par fui le pays
varma en france et que ils ont
l'impression de se vider de leurs forces
vives que les démocraties des mots
démographie dans ces pays est
extrêmement très peu d'enfants par femme
on a une bd des pays qui se dépeuple des
villages qui disparaissent et ça ça crée
une tension très forte et moi ce que je
veux qu'on comprenne c'est que le
problème n'est pas avec dans le problème
c'est les causes de viktor orban
les prem's et le cause de ces populisme
qui pour moi sont dangereux ils sont
dangereux pour la démocratie ne sont
dangereux par la paire dames
préservation des droits qui sont
dangereux d'abord pour les polonais
regardez les manifestations sur la
remise en cause la zone de droits des
femmes qu'ils aient lieu et sur le bras
de l'avortement qui est qui qui a eu
lieu en pologne
regardez la manière dont certains
migrants sont traités en hongrie dans la
manière dont certains journalistes sont
traités aussi c'est des choses qui sont
dangereuses
le problème c'est que ces choses
dangereuses des arrive parce que
justement on a une mauvaise architecture
européenne parce que on pousse les
peuples à comment dire à se faire
concurrence et est donc plutôt que de
s'offusquer de ce qui se passe il faut
aussi en tout cas c'est mon sentiment
c'est qu'il faut aussi de comprendre
échanger ce qui peut se faire parce que
moi je pense qu'il faut sauver la
liberté il faut sauver la démocratie et
qu'elle est véritablement danger et il
faut pas croire que ce soit limitée à
l'europe centrale moi je vois la
démocratie en danger dans d'autres pays
y compris en france on voit la
difficulté qu'on commence à avoir de
débattre de sujets politiques voire nos
sujets médicaux
puisque tout d'un coup on est forcément
à la solde du système ou alors au
contraire des populistes complètement
démagogues cesser là on voit aussi que
la démocratie c'est pas juste le vote
s'est même pas juste un livre comme on
tient le vote libre c'est aussi lors des
nations correcte du débat si aussi tout
un ensemble d'institutions qui
aujourd'hui sont extrêmement affaibli
c'est moi c'est ça qui m'inquiète si
vous voulez dans cette affaire-là qui à
mon avis n'est pas propre à la pologne
en hongrie qui qui arrive aussi dans
d'autres pays
elle fait à wang est hinault y aurait il
y aurait beaucoup
beaucoup à dire sur la dépendance sur la
liberté de la presse je pense qu'il ya
en effet un vrai sujet l'union
européenne ne doit rien lâcher sur ce
sujet la télévision publique hongroise
est aujourd'hui proche le proche lorsque
j'ai écrit mon livre le nouveau procès
de l'est et en discuter directement avec
le ministre de la justice se lassent
l'autre au king de crosse à 10 de 2014 à
2009 qui reconnaissait en effet que la
division public était proche du pouvoir
et qui le disaient instaurant à ce
moment là une règle européenne valable
pour l'ensemble des états qui disent
comment doit fonctionner une télévision
publique en europe et après tout
pourquoi pas ça peut être un sujet à
mettre sur la table
en tout cas je pense que derrière il ya
une question celle de la pure à lise
pluralisme dans le débat public et elle
se pose en hongrie et elle se pose aussi
dans d'autres dans d'autres pays je
répondrai à david caïla sur la question
de 1 nouvel ordre mondial qui
viendraient imposer ses vues à ces états
nations dont il n'y a pas de n'y a pas
de complot mondial en revanche il ya une
union européenne que rose et manuel
barosso définissait comme un empire non
impériale qui impose sa discipline non
par la force mais par le droit et donc
nous avons une vraie discussion à avoir
sur l'état et donc sur l'état de droit
concernant l'indépendance est un mot que
l'on brandit un peu vite c'est dommage
il ya une vraie réflexion entre juristes
au niveau européen sur le
constitutionnalisme hongrois il faut
savoir que les réformes mises en oeuvre
en hongrie ont été largement inspiré de
la tradition républicaine française qui
comme vous le savez fait cohabiter au
fond état fort et état de droit et vous
savez notamment qu'en france il n'y a
pas de pouvoir judiciaire il est une
autorité judiciaire et cela est
directement le produit de notre histoire
révolutionnaire et républicaine de ce
fait la france fait régulièrement
sermonné puisqu'il n'ya pas de dresde et
véritable indépendance entre le parquet
et le ministère de la justice ce qui est
reproché aujourd'hui à la pole man sur
le droit des minorités
c'est très intéressant ce qui s'est
passé en pologne
récemment vous avez en effet le tribunal
constitutionnel qui a estimé qu'il
fallait limiter le droit à l'avortement
lorsque l'avortement concernent des
personnes dont le handicap des enfants
en corner mais dont le handicap est
avéré à travers des tests prénataux
cette décision du tribunal
constitutionnel peut évidemment nous
choquer à l'ouest qui avons une
conception plus libérale de ceux de ce
point de vue mais elle a été prise en
pologne
ara tribunal constitutionnel ou non du
principe de non-discrimination principe
de non discrimination qui est inscrit
dans les valeurs fondamentales de
l'union européenne et c'est à partir des
valeurs fondamentales de non
discrimination que nous souhaitons que
la pologne et langres il met en oeuvre
un certain nombre de réformes favorables
ou lgbt
vous voyez là vous avez une valeur
fondamentale et à la non discrimination
et qui en fonction des cultures
nationales des contextes nationaux des
contextes politiques peut donc dans la
substance peut varier ce qui me rappelle
une phrase du grand juriste alain supiot
que j'aime beaucoup rappelé le droit
repose sur des croyances fondatrice
au fond il est aussi la traduction
technique l'infrastructure éthique et
qui renvoie à une histoire encore une
fois des pays et choix que l'union
européenne avant d'avoir un problème
avec la hongrie a un problème avec
l'histoire des nations des nations
européennes
au fond je dirais que nous avons sur la
question d'indépendance de la justice et
je finirai peut-être sur ce point eu un
débat à voir qui est à peu près le même
que nous avons que les états unis on tue
dernièrement suite à la décision de
donald trump de nommer un nouveau juge à
la cour suprême
d'obédience disons conservatrice les
réactions en europe ont été de dire la
cour suprême américaine va à travers sa
jurisprudence mettre en place une forme
de révolution conservatrice cette juge a
tout de suite précisé le rôle une cour
suprême n'est pas de faire parler la
constitution tordre le bras du
législateur elle est de coller à la
lettre constitutionnel de ne pas
interpréter la constitution mais de
rester fidèle au fond au texte initial
eh bien nous avons ce même débat
aujourd'hui en europe mais il n'est pas
posée dans ces termes avec une hongrie
au fond qui défend cour suprême
hongroise qui collerait à la
constitution hongroise qui a en effet
une tonalité conservatrice depuis
sa réforme en 2012 et une union
européenne qui elle à travers notamment
la jurisprudence des courses
supranationale a une conception je
dirais très interprétative des textes
des textes européens donc nous avons
d'un côté un clivage entre les ceux qui
veulent une cour suprême
colas la lettre constitutionnel et ceux
qui veulent des cours suprêmes qui
interprètent les textes constitutionnels
pour correspondre aux évolutions de la
société
moi je dis dans mon livre c'est qu'au
fond les évolutions de la société ce ne
sont pas aux juges de d'estimer quelles
sont elles
c'est aux politiques légitimé par le
suffrage universel
lui seul peut déterminer quelles
évolutions sont légitimes à être
entériné dans le droit du pays dont il
est le représentant
on finir parce qu'il nous reste plus que
cinq minutes
si ils n'arrivent pas à se réconcilier
parce que encore une fois je l'enjeu est
grave a le budget de relance et 750
milliards
c'est une forme de deux pas vers le fer
le fédéralisme au niveau budgétaire
un ski à dsk aurait moyen de sévir
aujourd'hui contre la hongrie la pologne
la slovénie éventuellement françoise
grosse tête puisque vous aviez voté vous
même des sanctions à l'époque en tout
cas contre le fit days contre le parti
de viktor orban est ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'union européenne a des moyens de faire
pression sur des pays récalcitrants et
doit-elle le faire bien entendu tout
d'abord moi je vais je rester optimiste
je suis persuadé qu'on va trouver la
solution
d'abord parce que nous sommes sous
présidence allemande la chancelière
angela merkel termine cette présidence
au 31 décembre
et je pense qu'elle n'a pas du tout
envie de terminer cette présidence sur
un échec et sadi c'est à dire le
financement du plan de relance qui ne
serait pas fait et le budget serait pas
adapté donc je compte beaucoup sur la
diplomatie de la chancelière qui sera
tout à fait capable à mon avis de
trouver une solution que tu es un peu
alambiqué mais qui permettra de sortir
un peu de cette impasse je regarde la
phase 6 il faut que chacun mais bien sûr
il faut trouver une solution qui
respecte les intérêts de viktor orban et
hewitt la pologne et bien sûr les
intérêts de l'union européenne personne
ne doit perdre la face
la chancelière je pense doit chercher
cette solution là et je suis convaincu
qu'il va qu'elle va trouver cette
possibilité d'autre part je rappellerai
que il ya eu un sondage récent en
hongrie selon lequel les hongrois à 75%
se disent pro européen donc viktor orban
doit tenir compte de cela aussi il est
en somme il pousse en somme le jeu
jusqu'à un point très rouge mais il ne
peut pas non plus aller jusqu'au bout
jusqu'à la cassure entre la hongrie et
et l'union européenne
donc je pense que chacun va faire un
effort mais encore faut-il trouver cette
solution qui peut être ne satisfera pas
complètement les uns et les autres mais
ça c'est souvent ce qui se passe quand
l'union européenne mais je suis
convaincu qu'on va arriver à sortir de
cette impasse qui peut décider de ne pas
financer le plan de relance qui est
attendu par tous
angry man colom surtout les financements
vont dans les régions les plus
défavorisées les régions rurales et
les électeurs de ceux des gouvernements
en place en pologne hongrie et bien
attendre ces financements là donc je
crois que on est dans un certain jeu où
chacun joue le rapport de force mais à
un moment donné je suis persuadé qu'on
va trouver la solution en soi que vous
avez bel ami vous reste une minute une
minute
non j'espère effectivement qu'une
solution sera trouvée et qu'elle ne sera
trouvée encore une fois dans le respect
de ce qui fait l'union européenne
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que chacun doit
être compris on n'a pas le droit de
prendre une décision contre certains
états membres sur les sujets aussi
fondamentaux et au fond on n'a même pas
le droit je crois de se servir du levier
des financements européens pour faire
avancer une idéologie qui prendrait le
pas sur la réalité de ce que doit être
la démocratie en europe c'est-à-dire le
respect des démocraties qui fonctionne
dans chacun des états membres je n'ai
pas dit et c'est très important que la
démocratie c'était seulement le vote
il ya des votes en corée du nord ce
n'est pas une démocratie pour autant
mais ce qui compte maintenant c'est
qu'on puisse reposer le débat sur des
faits objectifs et qu'on puisse le poser
en termes de principes structurants sur
la liberté de la presse je le disais sur
la liberté sur la liberté d'information
sur la liberté d'expression et et et sur
certains principes clés il y a des
raisons de s'inquiéter dans tout jeu
leur je le répète dans tous les états
membres ont doit pouvoir avoir un regard
indépendant et neutre sur tous les états
membres de l'union européenne et la
manière dont la démocratie s'y passe
qu'est ce qu'on dirait aujourd'hui si
l'article 24 avait été votée en hongrie
qu'est ce qu'on dirait de ce pays qu'est
ce qu'on dirait de la pologne
si les manifestations des gilets jaunes
avaient eu lieu en pologne
on voit très bien qu'en france aussi on
doit s'inquiéter comme dans d'autres
pays européens de la santé démocratique
de notre pays et de tous ses principes
fondamentaux qui font de nous une
société libre c'est-à-dire fidèle aux
principes de la civilisation européenne
qui a je le rappelle depuis vingt-quatre
siècle mûri l'idéal delà de la liberté
et de la démocratie
je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est
en jeu dans un débat de cette nature
l'émission est terminée je vous remercie
tous les quatre d'y avoir participé
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]